بتعرفي عدد راويه لو انه العالم اللي
اكتشف السكري اتبع تعليمات النظافه وغسل
ايديه قبل مغادره المختبر لكان العالم
بدون اقدم تحليه اصطناعيه قصه غريبه عجيبه
قصه السكرين تبدا من مختبرات جماعه
1878 عندما كان عالم الكيمياء الروسي
الالماني قسطنطينه يقوم بعده ابحاث تخص
مركبات قطران الفحم الكيميائيه
في احدى الليالي عامله العالم لوقت
المتاخر وشعر بالجوع وترك المختبر وذهب
لتناول الطعام تجاهل غسل يديه قام فقط
بمسحها بمنديل وبدا في الاكل
العالم لاحظ حينها طعما كثيرا الحلاوه في
الاكل في الوقت الذي لم يكن يحتوي الاكل
على السكر فاستنتج ان المواد التي بقيت
عالقه في يديه من قطران الفحم هي التي
اعطت الطعام هذا المذاق الحلو بحث عن هذه
الماده وبعد عده اختبارات اخترع ماده
السكرين التي تقدر حلاوتها اضعاف حلاوه
السكر العادي
اختراع بديل السكر الذي اختار له اسم
السكري عام 1884
واعتمدته الشركات المنتجه للمواد الغذائيه
والمشروبات قليله السعرات الحراريه وكذلك
شركات الادويه ابتداء من سنه
1907 لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات